I got up early because I figured I
better watch Game of Thrones before it
gets ruined before gets ruined did you
watch it yes I know everyone's bitching
about it but now it's become a thing to
[ __ ] about Game of Thrones it's fine
and they had to end the thing let me
break it to you I was pissed off after
the first couple of episodes of this
season but I said wait a minute I got us
the to the end anyway the fifth episode
I enjoyed I liked at all I mean I liked
it all equally know what was happening
no that's why I liked it all equally it
was fun spoiling anything it's a series
finale you got to watch it that night I
mean the New York Post spoils the thing
on its cover today is ridiculous of
course that's why I woke up early well
the other thing I thought was rather
mercenary
was all those little endings of the
characters then that led you to believe
oh we couldn't go on that storyline no
no more storyline that's enough we need
a new show I just care about the dragon
take me to wear the dress Yeah right
let's go to Izzi in Connecticut you guys
got to stop talking too much about Game
of Thrones yeah we didn't giveaway
really much when he could give away
spoils but John has a rule about the
season finale told us he just said it
you should have paid attention Gary you
would have heard that get back with your
plantains bah bah bah boo oh no got any
plan take a look he's got him - oh my
god whole new bucket plantains bolts
I couldn't hear John because I was
chewing my plantains he likes plantains
Gary huh he's mr. plantain chip